- [Instructor] Let r be the
function given by r of theta
is equal to three theta sine
theta for theta is between
zero and two pie,
including zero and two pie.
The graph of r in polar
coordinates consists
of two loops, as shown
in the figure above.
So let's think about why it has two loops.
So as our theta, when
theta is zero, r is zero,
and then as our theta increases,
we start tracing out this first loop,
all the way until when
theta's equal to pie.
So we've traced out this first loop
from theta's equal to zero
to theta's equal to pie.
And then the second loop has a larger r,
so these are larger r's, this is when
we're going from pie to two pie.
And you might say, "Well why
doesn't it show up down here?"
Well, between sine of
pie and sine of two pie,
this part right over here
is going to be negative,
so it flips it over, the r onto this side.
And the magnitude of the r is larger
and larger because of this three theta.
And so when we go from pie to two pie,
we trace out the larger
circle, fair enough,
that seems pretty straightforward.
Point P is on the graph of r,
right over there, and the y-axis.
Find the rate of change
of the x-coordinate
with respect to theta at the point P.
Alright, so let's think
about this a little bit.
They don't give us x
as a function of theta.
We have to figure out that
from what they've given us.
So just as a bit of a polar
coordinates refresher,
if this is our theta, right over there,
this is our r, and that would be a point
on our curve for this theta.
Now how do you convert that to x and y's?
Well you can construct a little bit
of a right triangle right over here.
And we know from our basic trigonometry
that the length of this
base right over here,
this is going to be the hypotenuse.
Let me just write that, that's
going to be our x-coordinate.
Our x-coordinate right over here
is going to be equal to our hypotenuse
which is r times the cosine of theta.
If we wanted the y-coordinate
as a function of r and theta,
it'd be y is equal to r sine of theta,
but they don't want us to worry about
y here, just the x-coordinate.
So we know this, but we want
it purely in terms of theta.
So how do we get there?
Well what we can do is,
take this expression for r,
r itself is a function of theta,
and replace it right over there.
And so what we can do, is we can write,
well, x of theta is
going to be equal to r,
which itself is three theta sine of theta
times cosine of theta,
times cosine of theta.
And now, we wanna find the rate of change
of the x-coordinate with respect to theta
at a point, so let's
just find the derivative
of x with respect to theta.
So x prime of theta is equal to,
well I have the product of
three expressions over here.
I have this first expression, three theta,
then I have sine theta, and
then I have cosine theta.
So we can apply the product
rule to find the derivative.
If you're using the product rule
with the expression of three things,
you essentially just
follow the same pattern
when you're taking the
product of two things.
The first term is gonna be the derivative
of the first of the expressions, three,
times the other two
expressions, so we're gonna have
three times sine of theta cosine of theta,
plus the second term is going to be
the derivative of the middle term times
the other two expressions,
so we're gonna have
three theta and then
derivative of sine theta
is cosine theta, times
another cosine theta,
you're gonna have cosine squared of theta,
or cosine of theta
squared, just like that.
And then you're gonna have the
derivative of the last term,
is going to be the
derivative of cosine theta
times these other two expressions.
Well the derivative of cosine theta is
negative sine theta, so if you multiply
negative sine theta times
three theta sine theta, you're
going to have negative three
theta sine squared theta.
And so, we want to
evaluate this at point P.
So what is theta at point P?
Well, point P does happen
on our first pass around,
and so, at point P, theta is equal to
theta right over here is
equal to pie over two,
so pie over two, so what
we really just need to find
is, well what is x prime of pie over two?
Well, that is going to
be equal to three times
sine of pie over two, which is one,
times cosine of pie
over two, which is zero,
so this whole thing is zero,
plus three times pie over two,
this is three pie over two, times
cosine squared of pie over two, or
cosine of pie over two squared.
Well that's just zero, so
so far, everything is zero,
minus three times pie over
two, three pie over two
times sine of pie over two squared.
Well what's sine of pie over two?
Well that's one, you square
it, you still get one.
So all of this simplified to
negative three pie over two.
Now it's always good
to get a reality check.
Does this make sense
that the rate of change
of x with respect to theta is
negative three pie over two?
Well think about what's happening.
As theta increases a little bit,
x is definitely going to decrease,
so it makes sense that we
have a negative out here.
So, right over here, rate of change of x
with respect to theta,
negative three pie over two.
As theta increases, our
x for sure is decreasing,
so at least it does make intuitive sense.